le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
à la réunion 6 % des déplacements
quotidiens se font en transport en
commun avec bientôt un million
d'habitants recensés le département mise
sur le développement de ce mode de
transport
depuis 20 ans il développe
l'emblématique réseau interurbain de
lille
le car jaune objectif le rendre plus
moderne plus accessible et plus
attractif
richard rené et l'udc sont les témoins
de l'évolution du réseau
[Musique]
le soleil se lève à peine à saint louis
sur la pointe des pieds
richard fini de se préparer la jeune et
nous on travaille et je travaille sur
saint pierre
jason polyvalent je prends pour m'amener
à la gare aux tirs de salon voilà 15 ans
que le saint louisiens se déplacent
quotidiennement grâce au réseau car
jaune
créé en 1996 car jaune fête ses 20 ans
20 ans d'histoire de transformation au
rythme des changements de la société
réunionnaise
rené mayer est employé au service des
transports depuis 1989 il a suivi
l'évolution du réseau au fil des ans
avant les quinze jeunes avaient le
réseau alizés à résonne toujours
départementale mais avec la mise en
place du réseau car jaune ça nous a
permis de restructurer le transport
intérieur bague de l'arrêt depuis le
réseau s'est modernisé nouveau linéaire
véhicules adaptés aux porteurs de
handicap wifi depuis 20 ans le
département développe ce moyen de
transport adapté à une population en
pleine expansion l'objectif était simple
c'est-à-dire d'offrir aux usagers un
service public de qualité à un moment où
vous savez sur un petit territoire comme
la réunion des problématiques
nous apparaissait problématique du tout
véhicule problématique d'un rangement
routier donc tout cela fait que il
fallait revoir
le mode de déplacement et affiné bien
sûr les déplacements en transports en
commun
des évolutions qui ne faut pas oublier
l'enjeu principal du réseau
l'accessibilité aux transports en commun
pour tous l'évolution au majeur pour le
réseau car jaune
c'est sur ces les services mais c'est
également la tarification qui est
important c'est une dimension sociale
parce qu'aujourd'hui les usagers ne
pourraient pas payer la vraie valeur du
coût du transport à la gare routière de
saint louis
brichart attend sa correspondance aussi
voit la voiture c'est mieux tu te prends
chez toi ça te dépose directement devant
ton boulot mais moi je suis un adepte de
ski des randonnées c'est moi ça me
dérange pas de marcher quelques
centaines de mètre voire 1 km pour aller
prendre le bus pour compenser
c'est ça ma nature un mode de transport
écologique mais aussi économique
moi j'ai un cadre unique parce qu'il
permet
et place et surtout les
quoi 60 euros c'est à dire posant
environ
par jour on peut utiliser
la chute aura tort une rate en dons
l'assurance est aussi l'entretien quand
actuel entretienne en main de la voiture
si richard n'a pas à se soucier de
l'entretien d'un véhicule
d'autres ont pour mission de veiller à
son confort dans le car oui ils vont
déchirer que la couture ou pour
reprendre un peu de plomb là et qui ont
réparé afin luc et sellier garnisseur
son rôle réparer les sièges d'endommager
là je vais préparer
de la moquette pour réparer nos sièges
donc on fait une série de traçage ce
métier ça fait 36 ans 37 ans que je le
que je le fais j'ai commencé chez les
compagnons et en fin de compte c'est en
étant passionné de voitures d'un que
dans l'avancée de mode apprendre le
métier ben la passion est venue
et depuis quand j'ai jamais fait autre
chose que ça alors sociale et là je vais
le prendre pour le démonter et les
choses qui n'arrivent pas bien expliqué
mais c'est vrai c'est une passion
d'avoir un cuir par exemple du cuir ou
du tissu et puis le transformer
maintenant là je vais récupérer la face
avant du tissu maroc est que j'ai coupé
et que je vais aller à la machine pour
faire la couture ont bien mangé en route
et c'est parti l'udc peut réparer
jusqu'à 15 sièges par jour
sa priorité les fauteuils des cars
jaunes l'écart j'en passe toujours avant
ça c'est obligatoire et on l'a reçu des
sièges 4 piège de cars gent de
l'exercice ben avait été bon c'était des
petites réparations mais obligé de
l'écarter
on voit que le cac reste trop trolard et
richard lui n'a pas perdu de temps après
15 minutes de trajet il rejoint enfin
son lieu de travail
même pas de bus de 35 comme le saint
louisiens ils sont 5 millions chaque
année à emprunter le réseau car jaune
un chiffre qui a augmenté de 13% entre
2015 et 2016
[Musique]
le réseau car jaune à compte désormais
de nombreux dispositifs au service des
usagers tels que des accompagnateurs et
dans à la montée des voyageurs d accès
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite un
réseau wifi à disposition des passagers
ou encore des horaires actualisé en
temps réel grâce aux écrans situés dans
les cars jaunes et les gares pour
développer le transport en commun sur
l'île le département gère depuis 20 ans
le réseau car jaune
plus de 300 personnes y travaillent
quotidiennement dont trente deux
accompagnateurs présents sur les routes
7 jours sur 7
le réseau compte à ce jour 17 lignes un
tarif unique de 2 euros a été mise en
place pour plus de renseignements vous
pouvez consulter le site www.camaieu.fr
eux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m